l'exposition occupe quatre espaces
distincts le premier chef life en
constante évolution présente sur des
étagères des ébauches de son travail
abandonnés en cours de route ou en
devenir on y trouve les matériaux qu'ils
utilisent le bois la pierre la
porcelaine qui sont le vert ou le papier
comme dans le second espace appelé des
positions ensemble de formes et de
matériaux archivée pendant 45 ans et qui
forment là pour le visiteur une
représentation de l'atelier à vient de
réflexion globale sur la sculpture et
son propos effectivement et pour lui la
sculpture est un regard sur l'histoire
de la sculpture donc tout à fait
effectivement c'est déjà une théorie une
théorisation de sa propre démarche
une réflexion sur casque la sculpture le
troisième espace regroupement familial
rassemble une vingtaine d'oeuvres
fondatrice est emblématique de son
oeuvre des années 80 à 2 mais elles
proviennent de collections publiques et
privées et ont intégré et soudain pour
l'exposition brouillon général ce sont
des sculptures quand ils te créer de
façon individuelle
alors parfois le fonctionnement en
diptyque par deux pièces réunies
mais la plupart ont été créés comme
pièce isolée
enfin le cabinet d'arts graphiques a
qu'à une trentaine de collages à 6k
travail important de céramique montrant
les facettes multiples de la recherche
d'un artiste qui explore la matière pour
construire et théorisé une oeuvre à
découvrir nord ses secrets de fabrique
[Musique]